c'est le monument le plus visité
d'espagne chaque année trois millions
deux cent mille visiteurs viennent de
très loin pour admirer la sagrada
familia
c'est vraiment très jolie
on n'a pas ça au japon
un chef-d'oeuvre en évolution permanente
commencée en 1882 la basilique est
aujourd'hui toujours en construction et
les visiteurs ne se lasse pas de la re
découvrir au fil de l'avancée des
travaux déjà venu il élevé de tels
d'années c'était le plafond ne n'y étais
pas donc c'est impressionnant au plafond
justement les colonnes explosant des
centaines de branche antoni gaudi le
créateur de la sagrada familia l'a conçu
comme une forêt la lumière perse comme à
travers le feuillage d'une canopée
l'âme que ça ça dégage quand on rentre
déjà intérieur et voir
ces pierres ses mosaïques sont dûment
pour découvrir les secrets de
construction de la sagrada familia
il faut s'enfoncer dans ses entrailles
dans l'atelier des maquettistes
90% des documents qu'il nous reste de
gaudi sont des maquettes il faut les
conserver les restaurer les étudier pour
comprendre comment ils travaillaient
comment il dessinait
depuis la mort de gaudi en 1926 les
techniques n'ont pas changé cette pièce
est une reproduction 100 fois plus
petites du futur sommet d'une tour
pour une pièce il nous faut à peu près
15 jours de travail parce que tout est
fait à la main
80 mètres plus haut
jordi fauli dirige les travaux il est
l'architecte en chef de la basilique le
9e a succédé à gaudi en près d'un siècle
ici on construit l'escalier en colimaçon
pour le futur axe et autres et là on
construit la base de la tour de
jésus-christ est juste cette base aura
20 mai 2
ils sont 240 à travailler sur ce
chantier hors norme à terme la
silhouette de la sagrada familia sera
monumentale
la tour la plus haute mesurera 172
mètres de haut et sera au centre depuis
les rues aux alentours on verra surtout
les façades mais en s'éloignant on
pourra contempler l'ensemble de 18 lourd
conçu par gaudi ce sera un ensemble
architectural extraordinaire
les architectes de la basilique ont
réalisé cette animation exceptionnelle
en trois dimensions
la plupart des 18 tours reste encore à
construire
[Musique]
comme le souhaitait gaudi le financement
des travaux dépend entièrement de dons
privés les architectes espère achever la
construction de la sagrada familia en
2026 pour le centième anniversaire de la
mort de son créateur
[Musique]